bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
malgré la crise sanitaire qui aura un
impact et toute l'année 2020 certains
projets impulsés ont été maintenus sur
saint quentin en yvelines c'est le cas
notamment dans le domaine des transports
trains bus vélos trottinettes navette
autonome ça bouge sur l'agglomération et
je vous propose d'en faire le tour c'est
parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 2020 la vie sociale et économique ont
été mis en berne du fait de la pandémie
malgré tout à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
certains projets ont été tenus ainsi le
secteur des transports fait peau neuve
des chantiers ont été amorcées d'autres
sont à l'étude pour faire le point nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de jean
baptiste à monique vice président
délégué aux transports et à la mobilité
sur l'agglomération sur les mois et les
années précédentes où il ya eu des
investissements qui auraient été
réalisées notamment pour accentuer le
confort des voyageurs l'information la
communication pour valoriser aussi les
gares routières un des premiers
chantiers en tout cas qui a pu suivre
son cours malgré la crise sanitaire sur
la fin d'année 2020 c'est des travaux
qui sont réalisés dans les gares
notamment à la gare de la verrière
après avoir doublé le pont guy schuller
et instauré le tcsp les années
précédentes 2020 a vu le démarrage de
l'aménagement du parking relais mais pas
seulement les travaux vont se poursuivre
jusqu'en 2024
aménagement de la voirie juge et
alisation du parvis et poursuite de
l'aménagement de la gare routière place
de parking dépose-minute parking vélo
accès aux personnes à mobilité réduite
à la gare de ville preuve les claies une
première phase de travaux a été impulsée
en mars 2020 le parking a été agrandi et
végétalisée pour davantage de place pour
les piétons qui peuvent désormais
profiter de bancs publics l'accès à la
circulation a été corrigée pour plus de
fluidité
y compris pour les transports en commun
des études sont actuellement à l'oeuvre
pour y développer la multimodalité
[Musique]
et
je prends le train et le bus des lignes
n la cia ou les transports pour moi
c'est indispensable mais plutôt bien
servi parce qu'il ya quand même trois
lignes autre chantier autres gars à
montigny le bretonneux
c'est la gare un peu centrale si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi de vue du territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines là aussi avec
de nombreuses lignes de bus qui
permettent de la desservir c'est aussi
la localité où nous avons la vélostation
ce qui est important pour le territoire
de l'agglomération là aussi où nous
avons lagence actuel de la mobilité
et tout ça en tout cas laisse est aussi
important parce que nous rentrons en
2021 sur une mise en concurrence du
marché de bus où nous avons aussi
l'objectif d'avoir un opérateur unique
pour gérer à la fois le réseau de bus
mais aussi la vélostation --l'agence de
la mobilité
depuis le 14 décembre dernier une
nouvelle desserte a vu le jour un
nouveau train semis directs entre paris
montparnasse et la gare de saint quentin
en yvelines
une nouvelle offre qui s'ajoutent aux
semis direct de la ligne n
né en 2019 mais la transformation ne
s'arrête pas là cette guerre est la plus
fréquentée du département 70 mille
voyageurs et transitent chaque jour en
elle sera bien plus fréquente est encore
en effet certaines disciplines
olympiques se dérouleront sur saint
quentin en yvelines un programme de
travaux conduits par la sncf a d'ores et
déjà été entamées depuis octobre dernier
accessibilité hockey par tapis roulant
qui eux même modifié et rallongé pour
des rames plus spacieuse de nouvelles
portes de validation pour faciliter les
flux et l'accessibilité pour les
personnes à mobilité réduite
les abords de cette gare seront
également desservis par un réseau de
navettes autonome une première en milieu
périurbain
c'est la première expérimentation en
tout cas en partenariat avec
l'ile-de-france mobilité qui a lieu sur
dont on va dire en conditions réelles
avec les autres acteurs de la route donc
on est sur un itinéraire d'un 6 km une
navette autonome qui partira de la place
bicloo à proximité de la gare de
montigny pour rejoindre justement la
zone d'activités du pas du loup ou là
nous avons plusieurs entreprises qui
seront desservies une navette qui sera
donc son chauffeur comme son nom
l'indiqué autonome
l'objectif de cette expérimentation
lassé de voir comment cette technologie
se comporte à la fois avec des piétons
avec des automobiles et voir si c'est un
mode de déplacement en tout cas qui peut
être pérennisé la fréquence entre les
navettes sera de 7 à 8 minutes
l'inauguration de ce service gratuit
devrait avoir lieu en mars prochain
qui dit paul gardy réseau de bus celui
ci a été renforcée ces derniers mois ont
fait le point moi je penses tu mens le
bus parfois 415 et avant je prenais
beaucoup de 414 34 60
déjà on a quand même un réseau bus qui
s'est assez bien avec la gare routière
russe au salon haut niveau nous
transporte libyens disent à vue je suis
il ya des nouvelles lignes de bus où
vous c'est quoi c'est très bien desservi
pas seulement où je n'ai pas à me
plaindre de ce côté-là l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise est desservie par 90
lignes de bus ces derniers mois le
réseau a été renforcé certaines courses
ont été augmentés d'autres lignes ont vu
leur parcours étant dû modifier un bus
articulé a été mis à la disposition des
élèves du lycée de villeroy vie nouvelle
ligne sont désormais accessibles aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
aujourd'hui on est sur cette logique de
performance et de maillage avec des
travaux aussi qu'ils sont réalisés en
termes d'accessibilité notamment pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
donc là on a des on a aussi des mises en
accessibilité et en conformité d'arrêt
de bus donc ce réseau de bus qui est
aujourd'hui
une vraie valeur ajoutée pour le
territoire et qui permet justement à nos
concitoyens saint quentinois de se
déplacer est un réseau qui fonctionne
bien court en 2021 la mise en
concurrence devrait aboutir au choix
d'un opérateur unique
celui-ci gérera l'ensemble du réseau de
bus sur tout le territoire saint
quentinois ainsi que l' agence de la
mobilité
autre mode de déplacement qui fonctionne
à la bicyclette celle ci est reine sur
le territoire saint quentinois qui
possède quatre cent vingt kilomètres de
pistes cyclables et ce n'est pas fini
le vélo est définitivement devenu un
mode de déplacement à part entière moi
je fais du vélo aussi malgré mon grand
âge ça m'arrive de prendre de belhout
temps en temps je fais du vélo sur la
base de loisirs verts de saint quentin
en yvelines j'ai vu que les les
les pistes cyclables c'était s'était
développée il faut continuer à les
rallonger les améliorer mais y en a déjà
beaucoup c'est super mal sur le vélo qui
est une mobilité mobilité douce et
durable évidemment aussi que nous voyons
comme une mobilité structurantes sur le
territoire qui a vocation à participer à
l'intermodalité c'est à dire que on ne
compte pas évidemment sur le vélo pour
sub pour se substituer c'est pas du tout
l'ambition au réseau de bus ou
transports en commun type le train
également en revanche c'est une solution
de mobilité supplémentaire et
complémentaire de ce fait en 2020 des
couronnes à piston été mise en place à
la suite du premier confinement pour
faciliter les déplacements
aujourd'hui on a pu en tirer le bilan on
voit qu'il ya des endroits ou faction
que ça fonctionne je trouve ça
fonctionne pas il ya eu effectivement
quelques itinéraires cyclables qui ont
été réalisés du côté de guyancourt
également sur la rd 36 parce qu'on sait
c'est qu'il y a eu un effet confinement
et déconfinement assez notable en tout
cas en ce qui concerne la pratique du
vélo
on l'a vu quand on a lancé une opération
promotionnelle sur la vélostation tous
les vélos sont partis très rapidement
vélos loués en longue durée ou encore
vélo électrique l'engouement a été
immédiat
l'état et la région aide à l'achat ou à
la réparation des vélos personnels
c'est pourquoi l'agglomération se
concentre sur les itinéraires à
l'échelle des douze communes du
territoire
le but est d'avoir un maillage
intercommunale qui couvre l'ensemble des
villes le nouveau schéma directeur
cyclable devrait être arrêté pour avril
prochain
ce qui nous permettra d' acte et quels
sont les nouveaux itinéraires que nous
souhaitons créer quels sont ceux qui
vous nous faut requalifier
quels sont ceux qui sont jugés aussi
prioritaires en entretien que demandent
aujourd'hui des utilisateurs du vélo ou
ceux qui sont en tout cas utilisateurs
en devenir c'est de pouvoir avoir des
liaisons cyclables sécurisées entretenu
et évidemment qui fasse sens et qui
rejoignent des commodités entre
guillemets stratégique gare routière
entreprises loisirs qu'ils souhaitent
utiliser pour les trajets complet ou
lors des derniers kilomètres
le vélo doit être accessible pour tous
et à tout moment d'ici 2022 une piste
cyclable devrait relier l'île de loisirs
à la gare de saint quentin en yvelines
et au futur pôle high tech situés sur
les zones d'activités de la clé
saint-pierre et de peace à l'eau
[Musique]
ces dernières années la trottinette
électrique a aussi suscité enthousiasme
50 ans on y vit n'y échappe pas
l'opérateur tiers présent sur paris lyon
grenoble et bordeaux a remporté le
marché
sur l'agglomération au début de cette
année une expérimentation grandeur
nature sera bientôt à l'oeuvre c'est un
très beau sujet que nous souhaitons
porter on connaît aujourd'hui la
trottinette en milieu urbain je pense à
des grandes villes comme paris notamment
l'enjeu est tout l'intérêt de
l'expérimentation que nous allons mener
pendant un an avec un opérateur c'est
d'avoir une expérimentation de cette
mobilité douce durable qui permet aussi
toujours dans cette logique d'un
intermodal de rejoindre une gare
routière de rejoindre une gare
ferroviaire sur les logiques des
premiers derniers kilomètres le réseau
intercommunal de trottinettes
électriques devrait voir le jour en mai
2021 avec dans un premier temps une
cinquantaine de stations
voire plus si affinités notamment aux
abords des entreprises
les trottinettes à 20 km/heure
pour plus de sécurité seront fournies
avec le casque mille engins seront
disponibles pour le lancement de
l'opération dernier projet d'envergure
qui devrait bouleverser les modes de
déplacement l'instauration de la ligne
18 une ligne de métro automatisé kg à
relier l'aéroport d'orly à versailles
via le plateau de saclay et saint
quentin en yvelines la 18 c'est très
bien j'ai vu le projet
c'est intéressant surtout pour les gens
qui travaillent cela peut alors à
construire le pays leur vie éviter de
prendre la voiture s'améliore et
transparence et c'est toujours positif
d'un point de vue écologique je pense
que c'est bien c'est une bonne chose ça
peut éviter ou est peinte d'aller sur
jusqu'à paris et ça et faire l'aller
retour
tout ça ça va dans le bon sens ces
dernières années l'agglomération
saint-quentinoise s'est battu pour que
la ligne 18 desservent le territoire le
projet a été maintes fois négocié annulé
réenvisager avec l'état finalement la
ligne 18 passera bien par saint quentin
en yvelines et reliera la future gare
saint quentin est à guyancourt aux
autres grands pôles de développement
d'île de france
en tout cas la gare de saint-quentin est
sera sera bien sera bien réalisé
on est évidemment en lien très étroit
avec l'ensemble des partenaires du côté
de l'agglomération il ya des sujets sur
lesquels nous sommes penchés avec un peu
plus de précision parce que on veut
aussi pouvoir travailler en bonne
intelligence avec l'ensemble des
communes notamment celles qui seront
concernées par le tracé
la gare saint quentin est se situera à
guyancourt
mais les communes de
voisins-le-bretonneux et
magny-les-hameaux seront également
impactés par les aménagements réalisés
pour faciliter la circulation
actuellement ces derniers points se
peaufine la ligne 18 étaient
initialement souhaitée pour l'ouverture
des jo de 2024
moi j'ai bon espoir que nous ayons
justement cette 7018 attend
vous savez tout sur la mobilité en cours
et en devenir
à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]